[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vraiment avoir la foi pour être militant
se dévouent pour une cause qui leur
paraît juste
mais
[Musique]
quand deux militantes
ça c'est une bonne question
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que tous ces gens là sont
simplement les larbins des plus riches
ou drogué aux pratiques
et donc ça donne les militants plutôt
militaire quelquefois personnel même
fonctionnaire
[Musique]
entre de la partie c'était vraiment à la
limite
exagéré mais de ceux de se prostituer 2
x 2 2 2 perd sa liberté
[Musique]
oh
vous ne pensez quoi des militants
disons en voie de disparition et mi
temps on s'est posé moins de questions à
l'époque et on pensait qu'on pouvait
changer la société avec un grand g comme
ça d'un seul coup changer la société
avec un grand g voilà donc l'espoir qui
anime cette espèce en voie de
disparition mais ça s'attrape comment le
militantisme c'est génétique avec un
grand t ou contagieux avec un grand cas
en fait ça peut s'attraper tout petits
et même par téléphone j'ai fait le 11
j'ai regardé dans l'annuaire j'ai
cherché cds et j'ai téléphoné j'ai
adhéré au front un jour en allant un
meeting en tant que spectateur et à la
sortie sur le trottoir d'en face il y
avait des communistes qui nous
invectiver et ce jour là je me suis dit
ben là c'est trop ça peut aussi ça te
rappeler par le tract avec des
éditoriaux sur l'actualité politique est
jamais bien plus ça peut satrapi par la
bande l'équipe n'a plus déjà parce que
moi avant la politique fait surtout les
gens
ça peut s'attraper en famille comment
faire pour être capable de s'endormir le
soir en se disant tout le monde est
dégueulasse mais tant pis moi j'ai
plutôt mon petit nid je suis tranquille
je suis peinard et je bougerai pas mais
ça s'attrape surtout par la famille
j'ai baigné dedans quand j'étais petit
vos parents étaient donc déjà fait des
militants syndicaux et
et politique aussi je crois qu'à mon âge
mon père était un peu engagé oui à
droite aussi vous lire un votre âge il
l'était qu'il ne l'est plus voilà depuis
mon âge et les teignes à l'épée et pas
de conflits d'idées d'entre eux n'ont
pas fondamentalement ils étaient
divergents vous savez la droite et là
c'est pas très unie donc
mais ça reste toujours dans les familles
dans les deux sens du terme
mais ça n'est pas forcément héréditaire
donc j'avais un grand père et un oncle
qui eux étaient militants communistes
qui conservait cette ferveur là quand on
est fils d'italiens immigrés de la
deuxième génération
on est forcément très sensible aux
problèmes identitaires on est pendant
quelques temps tu n'es plus italien mais
on parle un peu italien chez toi tu es
débat français parce que parce que c'est
pas évident donc je me suis dit que le
problème de l'attachement à un groupe
constitué était indispensable à la vie
d'un être humain
ainsi le choix de daniel lui semble
clair ce n'est pas toujours le cas quand
on est militant débutants
pour vous la philosophie du front
national c'est quoi
je pense que c'est aimer les gens en
général
les servir du mieux
et puis et puis il y aurait tant de
choses à dire je ne sais pas trop à
gauche aussi le choix de société pour
porte encore quelques zones floues quand
on débute
la même que dans les pays socialistes
surfer non puisque ça a échoué on n'a
pas envie de de faire échouer la société
la actuelle on veut on veut proposer
quelque chose d'autre c'est fin d'une
autre façon c'est enfin c'est pas la
même situation de toute façon là il n'y
a pas oui le pays la niche y avait
beaucoup plus de moyens
[Musique]
et se porte davantage à l'essor du
communisme un pays plus riches où il ya
plus de moyens
ouais pourquoi parfum je ne sais pas
mais il ya évidemment des jeunes déjà
bien rôdé au parcours du militant par
exemple jean luc et ses camarades de
l'ajc jeunesses communistes
ils se livrent dès le matin à l'un des
exercices de base la pétition devant une
agence nationale pour remplir un plus
favorable que l'entrée de chez fauchon
ibo parfait
voilà il faut pas mélanger pas fini
vous arrivez souvent faire changer les
choses avec des pétitions des actions
comme celle ci si on fait rien déjà
c'est pas près de changer c'est foutu
d'avancé
par exemple mme astrid choc si on
n'avait pas fait cette pétition par
exemple y aurait peut-être pas eu de
référendum en france comme dans d'autres
pays d'autres pays c'est le roi machin
qu'à signer et voilà à quoi
leur rémy si on n'avait pas lancé cette
idée là et bah y'a des gens qui auraient
zéro franc et qu'on un petit peu
aujourd'hui il faut continuer le combat
mais c'est ça avance un autre exemple le
vote des femmes après la seconde guerre
mondiale bon c'était une proposition du
parti communiste
[Musique]
et si le midi ils guettent les jeunes
filles à la sortie du lycée c'est pour
le bon motif
des jeunes de toute la région parisienne
bon il y aura des lycéens des trucs
qu'on fait contre la drogue vous êtes en
seconde non et vous n'êtes pas là
j'essaie encore non
tu pensais tu
donnes et actrice d'ajc tout de suite
comme ça ça te permet très nette au
courant de tout ce qu'on fait et tout ça
il ya la grande affiche pour le débat
avec avec robert
et sinon ce qu'on va faire céder des
bombages aussi il ya des idées là de
textes
voyons déjà fait pour freiner
[Musique]
otcbb au
vote pour m'aider
le pen à l'elysée annoncé ça m'étonnait
aussi
j'étais lycée à l'époque je trouvais que
c'était archi injuste et j'avais envie
de changer
donc voyager du porte à porte on disait
et il faut le socialisme en france quoi
ca point c'est tout quoi et maintenant
dans tout ça on leur met on s'est remis
en cause quand même beaucoup est-ce
qu'en fin de compte le parti gaulliste à
mon avis il existait pas pour lui-même
et ses 15 outils pour transformer la
société et tant qu'il y aura du
capitalisme il y aura la lutte des
classes et il y aura à parti communiste
quoi vous pensez qu'un jour il y aura
plus de capitalisme en france ou
ailleurs je
ce à priori oui ça ça parait pas
utopique mais ça se fera pas comme on
imaginait les changements dans les pays
de l'est en 1917 ça se fera je pense
progressivement avec une remise en cause
par la population de tout système
que vous mettez des affiches à l'envers
parce que ça se voit mieux qu' au moins
s'exprima comment il sans quoi
c'est nous qui l'écrivons même pas
maintenant vous allez me dire c'est pour
pas dû mais les murs
on en met partout partout certes on en
est où le tout le long des panneaux
si pour certains l'affichage reste
encore un divertissement ça va bien de
repousser la première fois ce stade de
la vie
[Applaudissements]
vous avez des scrupules à recouvrir les
affiches des autres on dirait un peu à
peu oui
en général on regarde espèce de mode
easy lundi qui se fait qu'il serait on
en laisse un peu une de chaque on espère
que les autres
j'ai en permanence à cette école que je
voyais et j'attache avec 7 sél astique
la
colle un peu consistantes one manière à
ce que ça ça n'existe pas je circule en
permanence avec ce seau de colle et puis
un petit un petit lot d'affichés
desquiens un endroit un petit peu de
temps et ben je m'arrête
pour d'autres en revanche l'affichage
est une opération beaucoup plus élaboré
il faut savoir qu'au front national les
militants paille mais affiche une colle
et les tracts qui le distribue ça motive
non
[Musique]
voilà allez tu lidl
évitons d'avoir les problèmes
[Musique]
vous
vous arrêtez le fait
alors tout ce qu'on va faire don valley
d'abord les laisser partir j'apprends
leur avenir
[Musique]
front national nous sommes une machine
très rôdée pour les périodes d'élections
ça on est moi je vous avouerai que quand
une élection approche je m'en sens
heureux là au moins on va pouvoir vivre
et bouger
quand j'ai fini mes neuf ou dix heures
de fauteuils et bien je me concentre sur
l'organisation du collage d'affichés sur
les boîtes à chaussures les tractages
sur les contacts qu'on doit apprendre
pendant ces périodes là c'est presque du
100% mais qu'est ce qui fait courir un
dentiste comme ça à 4 heures du matin
trois fois par semaine le peuple
français est bloqué entre les migrations
d'un côté et les multinationales de
l'autre et qu'il faut beaucoup de
courage pour ce pour briser cette chaîne
voilà ça c'est le grand vecteur de notre
pensée
moi je pense que la plus belle phrase
que jean marie le pen est dit celle
nationalistes de tous les pays unissez
vous la france doit être française et ça
tombe sous le sens par excès qu'on
appellera de dire ça mais la france doit
être française mais l'italie peut-être
italienne le mali doit d'être malien
c'est normal
le pen alors ça vraiment 7 h f il a
prévu le fils en algérie la prévu le
sida il a prévu la l'effondrement
démographique il a prévu le pen c'est
l'homme qui prévoit bon
95 99 % des patients connaissent mes
idées politiques est-ce que vous avez
des patients dont les idées politiques
très opposés aux vôtres ah ben oui oui
j'ai des militants socialistes même un
haut niveau du parti socialiste qui qui
me connaissaient avant et qui ont eu
l'élégance l'élégance et beaucoup
apprécié de continuer de se faire
soigner ici et même avec humour c'est
sûr qu'il ait pas masochiste sa beauté
mais aussi je sépare est un gars
extrêmement gentil c'est tout ce que je
peux vous dire et aqua restons derrière
son masque pencher sur des mâchoires
béante ce que j'aimerais moi c'est être
chanteur d'opéra j'aimerais chanter
l'opéra eh bien j'aimerais que mon fils
joue du saxophone et voilà avec ma fille
de l'âge où l'art moi je fais de la
politique je milite pour eux mais je ne
veux pas forcément en faire des
militants si la situation s'améliore
quand nous aurons le pouvoir sur tout
pas militant
tant qu'il y aura des portes il y aura
des électeurs derrière
[Musique]
bonsoir nous venons vous présenter ce
petit questionnaire qui concerne la
dalle des olympiades je pense que c'est
essentiellement un travail de proximité
le travail de l'éditeur maintenant c'est
plus
essayez de faire du prosélytisme de
convaincre les gens de les ramener leurs
idées être à l'écouté partager leurs
problèmes au quotidien ils servent à
voir
absolument
ce qu'ils n'ont pas effectivement c'est
un contact plus proche c'est la
télévision fait par les médias en
général qui je pense sont fait voler le
travail et
rémy lui a décidé de s'engager ou ps
juste avant la défaite de la gauche ce
qui était prévisible paradoxalement il
ya plus d'engagements à la veille d'une
défaite est la veille d'une victoire
l'échec on y réagit de deux façons ou
bien par des déceptions par une attitude
défaitiste ébranlé mes convictions non
bien au contraire en se disant qu'on a
plus que jamais besoin de vous je pense
qu'il ya effectivement des erreurs qui
ont été faites mais le bilan n'est pas
si négatif que ça le sang contaminé a
été une des affaires parmi d'autres il
ya eu la corruption il ya eu surtout
l'échec majeur du chômage je crois que
tout le monde le sait aux musulmans de
ma peau des socialistes vous ne voudrez
pas ici
c'est à la fille que tu inventes
ensemble sans adhérer particulièrement
q pensez-vous des militants aussi
convaincu que vous mais par des idées
opposées ou votre
voix je pense que bon toutes les idées
sont respectables c'est vrai que j'ai
envie de leur dire qu'ils se trompent
mais je vois pas pourquoi je serais
haineuse par exemple à leur égard sous
prétexte qu'ils se trompent vous êtes
sûrs qu'ils se trompent oui
je pense qu'un bon militant est un
militant qui doute s'il ne doute pas il
n'a rien à faire dans un parti faut par
ailleurs je crois une bonne formation en
politique en économie en histoire en
sociologie vous pensez que beaucoup de
militants de cette formation
les militants réellement actifs oui ce
qui s'implique réellement dans les
actions militantes long à divers degrés
c'est vrai que le ch a des sympathies
socialistes
[Rires]
excusez nous de vous avoir dérangé donc
merci bonsoir et
le dimanche matin j'ai ma permanence de
section 1 où je louvre naturellement des
piges et un tractage très certainement
de prévu sur un sur un marché où est la
sortie d'un centre commercial et jeudi
soir je fais un collage
vendredi soir on a la galette de
circonscription oui mais alors à temps
parce que là il ya un problème c'est que
le même jour de 17h à 20h j'ai un
meeting de soutien à chirac pendant
injuste vous allez y au lieu cette
rencontre avec jacques chirac non magie
n'est pas puisque je suis pas
chiraquienne
ni managérial je vais pas aller à lille
réunion un contre avec chirac on est
d'accord sur sur l'essentiel je dirais
sur une grande vision de la société
peut-être mais on appartient laurence
appartient à l'udf et plus
particulièrement au parti républicain
moi je suis au rpr on a des sensibilités
différentes des petits accrochages de
temps en temps ça se passe quand même
pas mal il n'y a pas très longtemps je
sais qu'on a une je dirais pas une prise
de bec mais enfin vraiment nous avons
une discussion assez serré sur nos
positions respectives de soir lorsqu'il
ya de journal télévisé s'il ya un scoop
qui tombe une intervention ou un soutien
d'untel ou untel on réagit souvent à
chaud c'est vrai sur ceux à ce film
quelle est la différence de sociétés
quelles sont les différences de valeurs
qui vous paraissent vraiment important
et là
moi je me souviens lorsqu'il y avait des
rassemblements pour de pantin on voyait
les ouvriers arié avec les cotes des
leurs bleus et leur code de travail
pour venir soutenir chirac ça je pense
qu'on verra jamais ça dans un meeting de
soutien balladur parce que je pense
qu'en fait ce après il s'adresse quand
même à deux clientèles foncièrement
différente je dirais que souvent l'udf à
+11 comportement de club alors que le
rpr et plus proche c'est vrai d'un parti
de est un parti de militants des
sarthois moment donné qui soutiennent de
la durée que des gens d'être que des
gens actifs qui se tiennent chirac et
que des gens passifs pantouflard qui
soutiennent balladur c'est intéressant
de connaître ce cépage en s'étendant les
gens qui soutiennent les hommes
politiques c'est des gens comme toi et
moi tu es bien quelqu'un qui soutient un
homme politique oui on plaide ont alors
un mois plus tard laurence avait
raccourci ses cheveux et doit ces
sondages favorables alors madame
colombier depuis la dernière fois qu'on
s'est vus les les sondages ont changé
comment vous réagissez j'ai toujours
espoir soulevé toute manière les
sondages ça peut encore changer et puis
disons qu'on en parle peut-être un petit
peu moins contre nous en parler avant
elle reste persuadée que c'est un
épiphénomène comme les sondages de
balladur était hyper fort avant ça peut
se retourner pour elle de la même façon
c'est ce qu'elle pense moi je le pense
pas évidemment
enfin bic de toute façon ce qui est bien
c'est qu'on deuxième cours quoi qu'il
arrive on sera ensemble pour coller les
affiches
je reste sur mes positions où les pieds
je pense quand même que valent à dire
sera président de la république
et laurence repart afficher un
rassemblement sont favoris indifférente
aux simples d'esprit qui vont voter
juliette gréco
et voici le champ de bataille préféré du
militant le marché ici les dealers de
tracts rac le citoyen électeur c'est le
harcèlement textuel impossible
d'échapper au prospectus sur lesquelles
sont écrits noir sur blanc ou en couleur
les arguments qui tue à l'endroit ou à
l'envers on n'y échappe pas
difficile de fourguer l'indésirable book
papier sur lequel il ya même pas de
compte pourra gagner et qui sera souvent
jeté 10 mètres plus loin
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui la mobile patxi sent pas
bon parti socialiste en reculant tous
ensemble avec balladur dès l'été pop
corn
je crois qu'ils préfèrent des plus
grands moments aux autocollants
el fogon d'edouard balladur ces chutes
et chaussées de chirac là bas en
belgique en furie à bord de l'avion
quand des militants rencontre des
militants qu'est ce qu'on entend des
histoires de militants change un petit
journal contre un autre petit journal le
nôtre faisait fait c'est du papier glacé
s'écouler
on appelle ça ne l'était pas
l'arrêter ne
nions revoit à droite on est on saura ça
la diana port tous les goûts d'arrêter
les
entraves à la dure et je craquerais
position juste un oui c'est ça non mais
j'aime les deux
je le
fais avec mes enfants aussi sont en
vacances à l'époque à ce moment là on
devait aller voir les châteaux de la
loire puis on s'est arrêté parce qu'il
va marcher un marché et le
dans mon corps j'ai toujours des tracts
et j'ai dit aux enfants le côté je vous
achète une villa chacun et put en soit
je vais distribuer des tracts ce que je
veux pas que les enfants de fouace quand
même et et alors là le score a été
extraordinaire pour filles et je me dis
que c'est vraiment le travail des
militants pour lui qui n'est pas connue
si vous les kits apportant très
important c'était grâce à votre acte
voilà la région sicile un tract
lorsqu'il est thématique peut en effet
beaucoup plus intéressés un électeur
qu'un programme plus général vous voyez
là on est en train de distribuer des
tracts sur l'école c'est ce que jacques
chirac a choisi dans sa campagne ce
tract là peut on écrire changer d'avis
certains électeurs
étant lui-même est dérisoire ce qui
n'est pas dérisoire c'est la présence
sur un marchés et les gens ont
l'habitude de nous voir le jour qui nous
voit plus sur le marché by ils disent
tiens et socialistes ont disparu même si
on en distribue pas de trac c'est une
présence un qui joue ce sera ça joue
question présence le front national ne
lésine pas il parcourt les routes en
caravane précédant les grands meetings
jean marie le pen
accompagné de redoutables molosses il
crée néanmoins une atmosphère bon enfant
qui donne un air de fête à la dure loi
du marché
[Musique]
jean-marie le pen site devrait souffler
dans le pen vous adresser une lettre à
ses lettres aux artisans et commerçants
d'accord jeudi nous avons de sérieux
problèmes en ce moment il fait lui de
gros problèmes
pour la politique actuelle
je vous remets ceci fait vous informer
jeu là dedans seul aie aie aie aie aie
stylo avec et mon copain n'a pas droit
un stylo et alors tu as de la chance
copains
c'est de la part de monsieur
voilà jean marie bonne journée également
le front national est quand même accusé
de xénophobie de racisme etc comment
vous réagissez quand on sait que nombre
de nos amis sont sont noirs ou ou harkis
ou c'est totalement aberrant excusez moi
je peux quand même le dire à la caméra
mes cousins sont noirs mes cousins
harris du sénégal et alors
et alors vous voyez un drama ça à moi
pas non plus aimé mes camarades du front
national le rejettent ils absolument pas
j'aimerais déjà en photographie au plus
tard des malaises dédié au soleil
[Musique]
et si ça ne suffit pas dans la journée
la nuit quand tous les militants sont
gris des mains mystérieuse nourrissent
les boîtes à lettres affamés des
électeurs
c'est vraiment un investissement humain
et qui prend énormément de temps donc il
faut vraiment ça rentre dans ce qu'on
pense ce qu'on veut faire pour la
société on n'a plus le temps de rien
soit plus beaux course pour concevoir en
faisant les distributions de tracts
parce que sinon ça devient grave c'est
vrai qu'on fait
enfin moi je fais plus de sport mon mari
en fait un petit peu
dimanche matin soit bon les gens
n'allaient pas trop cinéma là on n'y va
plus du tout
il faut montrer l'exemple il faut être
là parce que les militants c'est ce
qu'ils attendent aussi de tout le monde
si eux ils viennent il faut que vous
veniez faut pas trouver des excuses on
vous êtes fatigué vous êtes fatigué mais
il faut y aller faut français est ce que
si vous aviez des enfants vous pourriez
consacrer autant de temps à votre
conviction politique non je pourrais pas
en faire autant je pourrais pas partir à
20h30 rentré à
00h02 trois fois dans la semaine c'est
pas possible puis meurt on va bien dans
notre équipe il ya des couples
même si des fois la femme aurait voulu
être là peut pas être là elle est là il
faut de temps en temps mais c'est pas
possible les week-ends on l'est on n'est
jamais là le week-end je trouve je
mettrai mes enfants si j'en avais et
puis aller tracter elle est allée au
meeting et tout ça quoi
l'action s'est d'abord des discussions
encore des discussions toujours les
disputes
pourtant s'il y en a bien qui ne se
contente pas de parler ses relances pire
qu ainsi le 5 février 1993 13h24 nous
sommes toujours en direct pardonnez-moi
mais le studio travailleurs de chansons
dans l'action on veut simplement
messieurs est
certain c'est vainement que votre
télévision n'a pas pouvoir donner moi
messieurs est ce que vous nous avez
téléphoné est ce que vous nous avez
sensibilisé à ces problèmes oui nous
voulons avoir pas une des explications
pour avoir cieux mais vous vous rendez
vous venez sur un plateau de télévision
vous prenez à témoin d'aider des
millions de téléspectateurs pour dire
que nous ne faisons pas notre travail et
bien il ne s'est pas calmée le roulante
[Musique]
personne les deux ans d'écart
sangatte et pia des haltes et les infos
d'un confort pour vérifier ce qui se
passe et si à des consignes voulait pas
savoir quand même rires allez
on va où là ben c'est top secret
on le saura la dernière minute et puis
toutes façons pourra changer en cas de
besoin on va son objectif des cyniques
japon la télé revue
une heure et demie plus tard roland
révèle à ses troupes le but du voyage
organisé là vous entendez ouais ben vous
entendrez comme 1 écoutez bien
nous avons décidé d'occuper la direction
nationale de la nba afin de montrer au
gouvernement qu'il doit répondre à notre
exigence aucun salarié de chansons à la
une près à
cette occupation est pacifique les
salariés qui travaillent à ne sont pas
nos ennemis
[Musique]
ok
tout le monde est prêt
mieux que ça tout le monde est prêt
cela
fait cher vous irez pc plus tard
[Musique]
il ne faut en aucun cas avoir une
attitude agressive
être déterminée ne nous empêche pas de
garder le sourire
bonjour
ses chaussons
bouffon filet nouveaux badges à dieu là
si
vous croisez le louvre et puis c'est
tout vous préférez qu'on casse
[Musique]
recherchez les volailles dans ma façon
en laisse
fonctionner comme objectif la mpl ans
nous sommes la société chaussons oui oui
on occupe tous les étages a plutôt nous
avons encore à créer 1000 salariés qui
risque malheureusement d'être licencié
jeté à la porte faso
[Musique]
très déterminés prêts à rester le temps
qu'il faut pour rester longtemps
mission accomplie rolland et son
commando pacifique sont allés à l'anpe
pour dire qu'ils n'iront pas à l'anpe
l'anpe on peut même écrire en russie on
veut j'ai compris
là qu il fallait reprendre le flambeau
pour véritable communiste et je suis
devenu
trotskiste au bout de quelques mois
moi je lutte pour que demain tous les
travailleurs soient leurs propres m la
balayeuse la concierge dit si le
travailleur qui conduit un bus est tout
à fait capable de prendre des meilleures
décisions que n'importe quel politicien
bourgeois que n'importe quel
intellectuel ou ou énarques ou n'importe
quel aux fonctionnaires
si certains agissent en commando il ya
aussi les solitaires pas les vieux
sanglier plutôt les jeunes loups
je n'ai pas trop frappé quand champion
des algues laddh
j'étais seul adhérent cds d'abord à
drancy et j'étais réellement celui qui
est avait à se prendre en main parce que
le relais aucune autre moyen que
d'humilité que de prendre son bâton de
pèlerin avec eux de faire un peu le
porte-à-porte faire le collage de faire
le tractage du tout faire tout seul ça
m'a permis de découvrir la politique
locale ce que vous avez un impact
concret lorsque vous faites que la
politique nationale ou bien souvent ça
se décide d'ailleurs sans vous et
parfois malgré vous détendre à changer
de président de la république je crois
qu'il est important d'avoir un maire qui
soit plus proche du président de la
république et l'état pour pouvoir avoir
les aide parce qu'on m'a parlé de
prendre pour cent d'augmentation de
loyer dans la
quand je rentre le soir soit j'ai des
réunions
j'organise des réunions de quartier soit
du tractage choix du porte à porte pour
justement savoir toujours ce qui se
passe dans les quartiers parce que vous
permet vraiment de sentir le pouls ce
que les élus ne sont pas assez en
général oui pour l'instant ce n'est pas
jeté
ma femme ma difficile de parler
d'élection présidentielle parce que je
sais à l'avancé
excusez moi de vous déranger je
m'appelle jean christophe lagarde mais
il faut être capable d'écouter les gens
et de rectifier ce que vous pensez est
ce que vous prévoyez en fonction de ce
que les gens vont vous expliquer de ce
qu'ils vivent réellement concrètement
que vous ne vieillit pas
bonsoir madame je m'appelle jean
christophe lagarde je suis conseiller
municipal à drancy si on veut jouer à y
consacrer 1 25 heures par semaine à peu
près quand même donc ça fait la moitié
du travail normale de quelqu'un qui fait
40 heures par semaine ça c'est difficile
de travailler de parler à quelqu'un
travers une porte oui bonsoir jean
christophe lagarde je suis conseiller
municipal à drancy oui je me présente
aux élections municipales je soutiens
d'edouard balladur mais bon il faut soit
edouard balladur ou jacques chirac je
suis à peu près d'accord avec ce qu'il
dit si ce n'est une question de méthode
et si vous êtes
si vous êtes avec une banderole en train
de dire votez votez intel et je crois
que c'est totalement inefficace la
télévision vous le faites dix fois mieux
que nous
d'accord non non on va pas rentrer et on
va vous déranger le fait que le message
politique passe par la télévision me
semble quelque chose qui dénaturent
progressivement la politique puisqu'elle
transforme le citoyen elle réduit même
le citoyen en simples téléspectateurs et
ça ça me paraît très très nuisibles
vous les étages c'est plus facile à
descendre qu'à monter donc on fait
toujours un immeuble en descendant
jean christophe lagarde prépare déjà les
élections municipales et pour aller
jusqu'au bout de son parcours du
militant solitaire il en arrive à coller
sa propre tête sur les murs
alors ça fait quoi que les sa tête sur
un mur
bien quand on est collé pendant très
longtemps la tête des autres la première
fois ça surprend beaucoup maintenant au
moment de la colle et ça fait plus grand
chose c'est le lendemain quand je me
réveille je me dis que je la vois encore
je me dis que j'ai passé la nuit pour
rien parce que des fois les affiches
elle disparaître entre le moment où on a
collé et le moment où on la voit le
lendemain c'est justement la brièveté de
vie je sais je sais c'est parfois
déprimant si vraiment on a passé toute
la nuit comme ça s'approchant à 5 6
heures du matin on essaye de se relever
à huit téléphones n'est pas évident
atteint plus fort hare et puis on trouve
toutes les affiches arrachées de ce
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui est passé juste
le matin derrière vous c'est un peu un
peu déprimant
[Musique]
militer peut parfois commencer ou finir
par la vie associative c'est le cas de
sylvain plutôt louveteaux que jeune loup
et qui joue dans l'équipe radicale
mais au fait ok c'est bon pour les
petits pots alors un de 8 et ça fait
quand même six ans que je milite donc
dans le milieu associatif et on s'est
toujours fait berner par des politiques
aujourd'hui j'ai envie d'entrer dans la
politique pour être sur le même plan que
1 du caramel aux roms les études de
kinésithérapeute j'ai dû les arrêter
j'ai vu les interrompre pourquoi parce
que quand on a 600 familles qui viennent
chercher des colis alimentaires vous
êtes obligés de jouer le directeur de
l'association est malheureusement sans
être rémunéré
[Musique]
j'ai des parents qui viennent me voir
pour me parler d'inceste pour me parler
de deux d'enfants maltraités donc il n'y
a pas que l'aide alimentaire autour de
ça il ya la médiation est est ce que les
élus en font aujourd'hui
de l'aide alimentaire il ya le football
il ya il ya une maison de l'enfance
alors la maison d'enfance est un symbole
parce que la maison d'enfance je n'ai
reçu aucune aide ni de la mairie ni du
conseil général respectivement la mérite
à gauche le conseil général est à droite
elle a
tout eu
aucun élu n'a apporté son aide pour les
travaux de cette maison de l'enfance
ses finances est tout simplement un par
un mais bourses d'études qui ont été
foutu là dedans par tout ce que j'ai pu
amasser comme économie depuis presque 5
6 ans et tous les budgets que j'ai pu
rassembler je les ai mis dans cette
maison de l'enfance
j'habite la cité je ne suis pas un élu
qui a un beau pavillon dans une de ses
villes aux alentours de la grande
couronne moi j'habite garges-lès-gonesse
dans un hlm et je mange comme les gens
qui sont ici mais afin de trier tout ça
on m'appelle le petit bernard tapie
local est ici à la tripe heures qui
qu'ils me voient arriver au niveau de la
mairie en se disant il va se présenter
il va se présenter imaginons qui va être
mère à 26 ans mais c'est peut-être
possible tout ça parce qu'il ya des
mères qui ont été élus à l'âge de 19 ans
21 enfin chose comme ça
il ya des radicaux qui rament et
d'autres qui pédalent denis aliments
boss du faubourg comme il dit n'arrête
pas de pédaler n'arrête pas de
travailler
émettant comme
l'indiqué n'arrête pas de me l'indiquer
d'ailleurs la salle de réunion radical
de belfort se situe dans l'un des
nombreux magasins qu'il possède elle
sert aussi de quartier général à énergie
sport qu'il a créé et qu'il dirige c'est
drôle ça me rappelle quelqu'un
j'ai racheté des entreprises en
difficulté je désire amener avec
beaucoup de travail avec une équipe
dynamique en phase de rentabilité
cette entreprise aujourd'hui fait 50 me
de chiffre d'affaires nous sommes une
cinquantaine de plaintes d'employées et
qu'est-ce qui veut changer de ni dans la
société avec un grand g il faudrait
qu'on arrête en france de taxer le
travail
un smic à aujourd'hui qui doit toucher à
peu près 4800 francs coûte 10 mille
francs à l'entreprise
un gosse qu'a appris à se battre pour un
objectif sportif demain ils transposera
cet amour du sport dans un amour du
travail cette goût de la victoire dans
le sport dans un goût de la victoire
professionnelle
et y aura moins de problèmes dans les
banlieues et y aura moins de problèmes
sur les stades et y aura moins de drogue
les 39 heures c'est très bien c'est très
bien j'ai rien contre les 39 heures me
mais je ne pense pas que c'est créer un
emploi à la cinquième semaine de congés
payés c'est très bien mais faut-il
encore avoir de l'argent pour pouvoir
partir en vacances et puis d'ailleurs à
quoi bon se reposer puisque sport
travail et politique sans les trois
mamelles du paradis selon denis
dites moi c'est c'est seulement parce
qu'à la télé qui
avons milité au parti socialiste avant
d'être radical et non quand même
toujours aimé les malins l'école quoi il
peut pas s'empêcher de travail alors il
faut vous montrer l'exemple
une affiche ne dure que ce que durent
les roses surtout si les verts par
exemple passent par là le lendemain
matin
et c'est bon non l'autre affiche
vraiment
de partage du travail c'est les femmes
qui doit céder un petit contrôle à ça va
c'est bien
pourtant ce moment dans une campagne
électorale des hommes politiques
traditionnels viennent parler du partage
du travail alors qu'ils ça fait des
années qu'ils n'en parle pas et qu'on
oublie de dire que les écologistes ça
fait 10 ans 15 ans qu'on fait des
propositions là dessus
on a l'impression qu'on travaille et
qu'en même temps on dérange donc on nous
entend pas
[Musique]
alain est ingénieur écologue incroyable
pour un écologiste mais est-ce qu'on ne
finit pas par fonctionner en circuit
fermé travailler dans ce métier ça vous
amène aussi la confrontation avec les
dures réalités économiques ou autres est
ce qu'on voudrait en théorie en tant que
militant ça se réalise pas aussi
facilement dans le cadre professionnel
donc les petits hommes verts ne sont pas
des martiens et si certains n'ont pas
tous les pieds sur terre d'autres les
ont franchement dans la terre manu par
exemple qui plantent une est symbolique
accompagnée par dominique venner pour
protester contre un projet d'autoroute
sur une nappe phréatique
alors ce qui veut dire à terme et est
pas si lointain une position phénoménal
delà de la pratique est donc une eau non
potable dans un proche avenir
ce genre d'actions ont souvent freiné
les autorités
pas vraiment mais on a bon espoir
on reproche souvent aux écologistes de
manquer de réalisme économique qu'en
pensez vous donne-t-il les les
dégradations son environnement et son
issue de ce2 de ce système là de ce
système économique l'ain si on change
les principes de base de l'économie
arrêter de produire n'importe quoi
n'importe quel coût de créer des besoins
inutiles par exemple c'était très rythmé
il ya des moments créer des choses pour
faire une valeur comme ça dont nous on
n'a pas forcément besoin partie
heureusement les évident qu'on est
on est sur le terrain économique on est
bien au courant on atterrit pas ça
mérite réflexion la gare avait ça je les
ai vous visez vous regarde on arrive à
convaincre ont à faire douter les gens
sur sur ce qu'on leur dit sur ce que
leur dit et ds que leur 10e le
gouvernement sur finalement qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de leur argent quoi
je crois que ce qui nous caractérise
effectivement c'est une certaine dose
d'utopie mais heureusement qu'on l'a je
crois que sans utopie on n'avance pas
notre seule faiblesse c'est d'avoir dix
ans d'avancé sur l'as sur la conscience
des zooms parfois
quand manu ne plante pas de haies qui
fait son métier maquettiste graphistes
sur un ordinateur qui marche avec de
l'électricité d'edf
si vous pouvez caricaturer les militants
écolos qui cale militant écolo n'a pas
son mac ou ne travaillent pas sur mac ou
c ou son portable branché sur son mini
terme sur son modèle son power faxon si
on prend comme exemple ne serait-ce que
l'énergie il est évident qu'on doit être
au top niveau des technologies et
justement parce qu'on allait passer pour
des doux rêveurs savoir que tout ce qui
est énergie éolienne et solaire
nécessite des moyens techniques très
sophistiquées et on est en constante
recherche justement ne serait ce que sur
le profil des pales des éoliennes ou
autre c'est vraiment
c'est de plus en plus pointues au niveau
technologique sévit dans notre volonté
le suivi social quand elle ne travaille
pas à la salubrité de l'eau il anime une
association de réinsertion sociale ou
des militants de différents partis
travaillent bénévolement ensemble a
besoin de faire
et c'est un pur hasard si rené ancien
militant socialiste écrit sur une
feuille rose et notre ami alain sur des
vertes où va se nicher l'identité prix
des tanks c'est seulement toi qui vas en
prison c'est tout tout le boulot se
partagent s'il y en a qui doit aller en
taule pour fausses factures c'est toi
[Musique]
moi personnellement vous savez j'ai une
carrière sportive
grande et longue je pense belle même
d'ailleurs carré carrière sportive et
cours de laquelle j voyagé dans le monde
entier j'ai côtoyé des tas de gens et je
n'ai jamais regardé la couleur qu'avait
la sueur de mon adversaire
alors actuellement c'est vrai que ça
fait parfois mal de m'entendre
taxé de raciste ou de xénophobe je ne le
suis pas mais par contre je donne une
préférence aux français dans leur pays
[Musique]
j'étais militant à l'époque où je
faisais du sport mais j'avais un petit
acquis qu'ils étaient j'ai un diplôme
d'humanité ancien parcours atypique que
celui de robert moreau qui après ce
diplôme d'humanité ancien devient une
star du catch dans les années 50 le
célèbre bourreau de béthune puis garde
du corps de jean marie le pen avant
d'exercer des responsabilités nationales
puis européenne dans son parti c'est une
ambition que je n'avais pas au départ
mais j'ai quand même été à la plus belle
école qui puisse être c'est celle de
jean-marie le pen
[Musique]
petit à petit nos idées ont été
considérés comme étant les seules
pouvant apporter une solution nationale
à la dégradation de la situation
plus la situation se détériore plus on
constate que les solutions que nous
proposions était peut-être les bonnes
pour y remédier qu'est ce que c'est vous
dire que si la situation s'arrange est
ça irait contre vos intérêts
non et je vais vous dire pourquoi parce
que si elle s'arrangeait ce serait avec
nos idées
donc automatiquement je serai satisfait
mais si vos propositions sont si
convaincante comment expliquez vous que
les autres partis de droite ne les
adeptes pas j'attends le moment où nous
considérons qu effectivement le front
national il vous venez un peu de le dire
est un des partis de droite et qu'il
convient de l'admettre à la table du
repas le front national est
incontournable un petit peu peur de
l'inviter comme je voulais dire la table
parce que ça fait une par an -
mais tout est le front national il faut
aussi le dire a bon appétit mais non pas
bon appétit par goût du pouvoir ou de la
puissance il a bon appétit parce qu'il
veut vraiment imposer ses idées
mesdames messieurs j'espère que vous
êtes bien calé dans vos fauteuils
accrochez vous à vos pantoufles
car maintenant les militants vous parle
des militants
premiers au hit-parade arlette laguiller
arlette laguiller elle est sympa elle
est simple mais faut dire que moi je
souhaite bon courage moi on a besoin de
gens comme arlette laguiller en ce qui
concerne les billets non halal est
étudiée et sympathique qui s'est
interdit travailleurs travailleuses à
l'heure actuelle est plutôt fou marche
aux luttes ouvrières du tout meilleurs
ils sont vraiment ringard quoi c'est
c'est tout juste pour eux s'il faut pas
une révolution à galactique pour changer
un petit bout de la société ce qui
allait communiste comme edf 36 oui
lorsqu'il avait vraiment des abus par
les patrons monde c'est une entreprise
en faillite qui ça se finit forcément
dans le bus parti socialiste est bas
mais on le voit très rarement existe pas
dans les entreprises sur les socialistes
ont les pires mois les socialistes sont
les pires l'idée d'un gros gâchis parce
que ce sont des gens qui essayent de
taper à la fois à gauche à la foux à
droite on ne sait pas quelle est la
position claire du herbert puisque vous
aviez les gens qui ont choisi le oui à
maastricht chez d'autres ont choisi le
nom en prv cher 2 rpr ou à l'udf il ya
libéralisme
intolérable va de vieillesse et même
combat que peine franchement ça m'agace
un peu enfin bon c'est séville et le pen
ne s'était dit pour analyse réalisme
intolérable je viens en une phrase vous
dire de villiers
depuis
[Musique]
employé
a mis ses idées à son service nous
mettons nos idées au service
national jusqu'au champion par l'écossé
on arrive de voir ensemble c'est
en tant que femme je peux pas accepter
ce qu'ils peuvent dire par rapport à la
place de la femme dans la société les
arcs et aux fachos les ce ceux qui sont
capables de tuer dans de tirer dans le
dos d'un un jeune comorien et puis il y
avait tous les paumes et tous ceux qui
n'avaient plus de famille plus
d'identité et qui se retrouvaient dans
son nationale parce que c'était droit si
terry gîte c'était rassurant les
écologistes sont
sont tout simplement
à mon avis des rouges qui ont trouvé
un moyen d'accès à la vie politique
comment dire qu'on n'a pas besoin de
verres en france
vous pensez que donc forcément tous les
autres partis qui n'ont pas les mêmes
idées que ils sont dans l'erreur si vous
êtes dans la vérité je considère que oui
ils sont dans l'erreur je peux aussi me
tromper mais mes convictions sont
ancrées en moi depuis tellement
longtemps que
j'ai l'impression que c'est moi qui suis
dans le vrai
un militant d'un autre d'un autre
mouvement c'est évident que de toute
façon vous lui ferait pas changer d'avis
et qu'il est sûr d'avoir raison comme
moi je suis sûr d'avoir raison
on n'y peut rien c'est comme ça je crois
tout le monde il a raison tous les
autres ils ont tort et pour mieux s'en
convaincre
pour partager son expérience à la proche
des grandes élections on vient recharger
ses batteries sous un chapiteau pour la
grand-messe le meeting
un meeting ça se prépare techniquement
soigneusement
efficacement
fébrilement
économiquement car il faut faire des
sacrifices nadim al
on arrive avec des heures davance on s'y
engouffre on s'y bouscule
mais surtout on s'y rencontre
[Musique]
là
on vend des petits souvenirs pour
alimenter les caisses du parti
au front national exclusivement on paye
sa place mais pour ce prix là on a droit
à un petit massage
[Applaudissements]
rhodia une communion importante dans un
midi mais d'abord de l'est
de leur rencontre fin de l'art parce
qu'on ne connaît pas personnellement là
on va voir l'ambiance tout ça mais il en
est un bien sûr oui l'ambiance ça mais
dans le 1 et pour chauffer la salle
chacun à sa manière n'hésite pas à
mettre le paquet
ici le paquet de gitanes
la clown et ses clones est
[Musique]
oh [ __ ]
ici on préfère les joies simples
loupé
[Applaudissements]
encore loupé
ici on suit en direct à la télévision
une interview de son leader qu'on va
retrouver trois quarts d'heure plus tard
ici même de georges
les cuisses
[Musique]
puis c'est le grand moment le lever du
rideau l'arrivée du leader il va être là
en chair et en os avec par ordre
alphabétique
d'abord la discrète arlette
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que ça lui roland
puis les autres un peu moins discret
[Musique]
les coeurs battent l'émotion est à son
comble
[Musique]
attention c'est bizarre ça
ce cross mme hamon s'est trompé ça c'est
les fans de bruel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
le meeting c'est ce moment magique où le
roi découvre son peuple de près
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai le coeur qui bat c'est sûr mais
c'est sûrement plus fort que l'émotion
où chacun sait trouver les mots qui vont
droite à l'urne railleuse travailleurs
de feuilles camarades mes chers amis
mes chers compagnons chers amis chers
camarades chers
[Musique]
amis amis du pont national chers amis
chers camarades et puis ils vont dire
avec leurs vrais voit à peu près la même
chose qu'à la télé valait 17 heures
superbe région 200
[Musique]
jeunes et du loiret et du loir et cher
de l'indre
qui vivent des choses pacifique
je vais vous dire pourquoi je suis venu
ce soir à caen vous dire pourquoi
[Musique]
il compte y séjourna craignent de perdre
tout s'il ne partage pas absolument
inacceptable ce rapport des autonomistes
de l'indre-et-loire de l'eure et loir ça
sera t'il pas plus gentil comme ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est une certitude on arrivera un
changement
merle vers le bas mais nous
ça ne nous empêchera pas d'emmener jean
marie le pen allait miser
iranienne il va gagner ça nous en sommes
tous certains
mais forcément à fer de lance mais à mon
avis le fer de lance de cette société
la ménagère du toit ouvriers qui
travaillaient sur la chaîne elle est
capable
c'est pas moi c'est tout le monde se dit
les chiens
alors le plus tôt possible mais je sais
que ça va
trois en réalité qui a toujours des gens
qui veulent servir les autres et qu'à
partir de ce moment là il y aura
toujours des militants
bon et bien maintenant on sait que
pendant son temps libre on a le choix
soit partir dans les tâches ménagères
soit à partir dans le dans l'engagement
à ce sujet faut jamais coupé le ris
parce que il va cramer
[Musique]